- Hello, everyone.
Thank you for joining our session today.
We are going to talk about
very interesting topic.
My name is Yaron and I'm
senior engineering manager.
And here with me Kevin
McGehee, a principal engineer,
and we are both from the ElastiCache team.
So today, I'm going to
start with introduction
to ElastiCache and Valkey.
And later, we are going
to dive deep together
on some advanced use cases
and data modeling that
I hope that you're going
to benefit from building your application.
So for those of you of not
familiar with Amazon ElastiCache,
ElastiCache is a fully managed
service that makes it easy
to deploy, operate, and scale
the in-memory data store on the cloud.
Now ElastiCache improves
significantly the performance
of your application by providing
a microseconds response time.
We support three open source engines.
We started with Redis open
source, Memcached, and Valkey.
Valkey is open source,
high performance key value data store.
It was fogged from Redis
open source last year
when Redis changed the license.
And last year, we also
announced that ElastiCache
and MemoryDB support the Valkey engine.
So today, all the example will be based
on the Valkey engine.
And to make it even more fun,
we decided to build together
with you, an application so
we can understand together
how all this data modeling can help us
to build a highly scalable application.
So Kevin and I choose to
build together with you
a massive multiplayer online game.
We definitely need to have
highly scalable technology
to support that.
We need to make sure
that we are providing a very low latency
and high throughput to our customers
so they can enjoy the game.
So let's start from caching
because caching is the fundamental
to make your application
to run much faster.
But I wanna start with
some high level concept.
So let's assume that we start
to build our application on EC2
and we have the persistent data stored
on some relational database.
I'm using here RDS.
So as long as our data is
going on a steady stage,
this architecture can works well.
But when we start to see
more workloads kicks in,
with read and write throughput,
we have multiple option.
One of them is to scale up our RDS
or to add more replica so we can scale out
and benefit from reading throughput
using the replication itself.
Now, RDS itself has the caching layer,
but it keeps the caching on paging
and blocks that does not
contain the result itself.
So from time to time, you
need to fetch the data
from the disk itself,
and there is some additional
latency that involved in that.
For that, we can choose
the Amazon Elastic Cache
that explicitly store the data in memory.
And once we start to populate
the result into the cache,
immediately, we can start with the data
from the cache itself and to
improve the query response time
and actually to receive a
microseconds response read time.
We can also relieve some
pressure from the backend
and from the database itself,
and we can optimize our cost
by allowing the backend to scale down.
Now, let's move forward and
see more advanced use cases.
I want to start to talk
about lazy loading,
which is one of the strategies
to handle the cache.
And I want to show you how
I'm managing that together
with in validation to the cache itself
so we can make sure the cache stay fresh
and without stale data.
So I'm using Amazon ElastiCache
and I'm starting to read the
data directly from the cache.
If we receive the data,
if the data is there,
we have cache it, all is good, we get that
in a microseconds response time.
If the data is not there, we
have a cache miss, then we need
to go to the persistent
layer, the storage itself.
Here, I'm using Amazon DynamoDB,
and right after that, I'm
updating the data into the cache.
So this is the way I'm
lazily populate the data,
warming the data upon every read.
Now, let's assume that
what of the item now
has been up-to-date and
what we are doing here,
I want to make sure the cache stay valid
and have the not stale data.
And for that, I'm going to
use the trigger function
that they have on the Amazon DynamoDB
and to trigger the lambda responsible
to invalidate the
specific item on the cache
so we can make sure that
next time on the lazy loading
on the same path, we're
going to update that data.
Now sometimes, we have a
very hot data in our cache.
And we also use time to leave
because this is the best way
to manage our cache memory.
And we want want to make sure
that the data is also
evicted from time to time.
So we are going to use expiry,
but if we have a very hot item
on the cache, we still want
to make sure that we have the way to read,
to update the time to leave
before it's got expired.
So we can benefit from keep reading it
from the cache itself.
And for that, we can allow
some background task to read
after the data, before
it's going to expire.
In my example here, I'm
using Valkey MULTI command,
and the MULTI command actually queued
multiple different commands and execute it
anatomically on the server side.
What you see here, I'm using the GET first
to receive the item itself.
And then I'm checking
what is the expiry time
that left for this item.
Now, in different example, as you can see,
we have multiple client
that GET slowly listening
the expiry until I'm going
to get the last client
that crossed the five-second threshold
and is the one that going to
update the data on the cache
to make sure that we
have more expiry period
for this hot item.
Now, as a connected to that,
there is the turn head
problem that we want to avoid.
This problem occur when multiple processes
or threads attempt to
proceed simultaneously,
often resulting in high content
and resource strain or a bottlenecks.
And this is something
that we want to avoid.
So let's assume that
I have a very hot item
on my cache that's about to expire.
Now, if all my microservice will try
to fetch the item from the cache now,
now they all will receive a cache miss.
What eventually will happen,
they all automatically
altogether we will go
to their database and we'll put
much more pressure on my RDS
and eventually, we're going
to impact our latency.
And this is something
that we want to avoid.
And for that, we can build kind of barrier
and synchronization
mechanism that allow only one
of the clients to request the
data from the database itself.
And only him going to update
and to populate it into the cache.
So once he finished
and when all the other is waiting for him,
we can read the data
and receive a cache hit.
So how we do that, how we build that?
For that example, I took
only two microservices
and I will go step by step
and follow you how we
can build it together.
So the first microservice,
try to fetch the item from the cache,
but the item is not there.
So we are going to receive a nil.
The second microservice
now is a bit slower,
try to fetch the same item.
You will receive a nil as well
because the item is not there.
Now the first microservice
will try to acquire a lock.
I'm using here the NX
and the EX arguments, which means that NX,
if the lock already exists, I should fail.
And EX means that I'm
going to expire the lock
after five seconds.
Because the lock is now is not there,
I was successful able to acquire them.
And then I'm starting to query
the data from the database.
Now my second microservice
try to acquire the lock.
And remember, because I'm
using the NX, I'm going to fail
because the lock is already there.
Now what I'm going to
do, I'm going to wait
until the lock will be freed.
So I'm waiting and periodically
until the lock is freed
by the first microservice.
In the meanwhile, the
first microservice finished
to fetch the item from
the database is going
to populate it into the
cache and free the lock.
After that, my second microservice
will be able to continue
and to fetch the item
from the cache itself.
Another advanced approach
is the client-side caching.
That means that if I'm even
more sensitive to latency,
I can use my local cache
to serve my on demand workloads,
which means I can benefit from
very low latency capability.
So for that, we have multiple
ways to achieve that.
First, the idea is very simple.
We're fetching the item
from the remote cache.
Once we receive it, we
store it on the local cache.
And from that point, I don't need to talk
with the remote cache because
I can serve the items,
the request for my local cache.
But there is a problem
I need to manage now
the data, the freshness of
the data on my local cache.
One approach is to use the
time to leave, the expiry
that I can put on my local cache.
The second one is to
subscribe to the remote cache
and to receive notification
upon every changes.
So let's see how it works.
The first and the default
approach of Valkey is to remember
to store all the data, the
mapping between the clients
and the keys that they accessed.
And every time we change one of the keys,
I have the data store in my Valkey
and I can update the specific client.
This is very efficient,
but from the other hand, we
need to have additional memory
to store on my server side.
The second way is to
subscribe to a prefix.
In my example here, I can
subscribe to user as a prefix.
So every time any microservice
that's going to update a key
with the same prefix,
I'm going to receive a
notification on that.
So how I'm going to implement
that on my client side?
First, we recommend as a key principle
to use a connection pool,
a long live connection.
The reason for that is because
creating a TCP connection
is an expensive operation,
specifically if you compare
to Valkey get and set,
which is in order of magnitude faster
than creating a connection.
Additionally, using a
client connection pool
with finite side,
reduce the overhead of
connection management
and it's also bound the
concurrent incoming connection
from then client application.
So what I'm doing here, I'm
splitting my connection pool
to two types.
I'm going to have connection zero
as the invalidation connection,
the control connection,
and all the rest from one
to nine going to serve
as the data connections.
Connection zero will subscribe
to the invalidation channel
and all the other connection
will perform the tracking
on redirect, on connection
zero, which mean
that connection zero will encapsulate
all the invalidation to all
the rest of the connection.
So let's assume that I'm
updating one of the keys.
Immediately, connection zero will receive
that update on the invalidation connection
with specific the specific item.
And we'll make sure to update
the data on my local cache.
Now sometimes, we are
thinking how to store the data
on our Valkey engine.
So it's very rich there,
there we have a lot of way
to store the data there.
I want to talk about two
types because in my example,
I want to store some session information.
I will start with hash data structure,
which is a very common data
structure to solve session data.
It's very simple because
it's mapped between key
and value pairs and we have the key
that directly access to the cache itself.
So in order to create the hash itself,
we're going to use the HSET command
and we are going to
provide them the hash name
and a list of peer pairs of key values.
We can also benefit from
a very fast random access
in a constant complexity
to receive a specific item
from the cache itself.
Let's go through a simple code to see
how easy it is to use that.
So here, I'm using a
Valkey GLIDE to connect
to the Valkey server.
And I'm generating a session
and I'm using the native hash map
that I have on my Python
to use the hash map.
Then I'm generating a
UUID that will be served
as the session ID.
Later, I'm going to use the
Hset command, the Valkey command
to serialize the hash data,
and using the session ID itself
to receive the data
from Valkey, I just need
to use the session ID that I generated
and I'm going to use
also the hgetall command.
And later, I can serialize
it to my local objects.
Very simple.
A different data structure
that we also recommend
to use is a JSON.
Very popular.
So JSON is a data structure that consists
of two main object, array
and key value pairs.
In this example, I'm
creating the JSON document
using JSON.SET.
and I can simply use the JSON path
to retrieve specific items from the JSON.
I can use to retrieve
it from the array itself
or from the upper level of the JSON.
I also can use the array append
to add additional item
into the existing JSON.
Very simply.
Let's go through a simple
code to see how it works.
So I'm connecting here to my Valkey server
and I'm creating the JSON
document at the beginning.
Then later, I'm receiving the email
of one of my users, very simply.
And same, I'm doing that
for to retrieve the age.
And I can also use the increment number
to increment one of the
indexes in my JSON itself.
So what is the main
difference between them?
JSON usually used
for a nested document while
hash is a key value pair
for more simple objects
like a session store,
while with JSON, we can do
use it for more complex one.
Now Jason supported Jason pass
to filter on the server side.
While with the hash, and
manipulate it on the client side,
but both of them we can modify
the items on the server side.
So we announced a few
weeks ago, the support
of semantic cache in on
ElastiCache, which can also retrieve
one of the best performance
for vector search in high ratio
of recall, of 95 recall.
So to understand the semantic caching,
we first need to understand
the vector banding.
You can think about
translating unstructured data
like documents, videos, audio, images
to representation of your data.
Now the vector embedding capture
the semantic relationship
between the different semantic elements.
For example, we text the
semantic awareness of a word
like a book can be sometimes
when we read in a book
and sometimes when we
are reserving something.
So to process the create the vector,
we involve ingesting data
from the source, splitting it
to chunks, and then it to vectors.
So let's assume that we have a chat bot
or some other application in our game
and we want to get a query
prompt from the user.
So we will use the same example
like I mentioned before,
like a book, but I'm
going to add the furniture
and finance here and we
will again visualize it
with only three dimensions,
only for the simplicity.
So let's assume that we
already we have a question
on our vector that say,
how long do I have to
wait for the next quest?
And then I'm receiving a new query.
That said, when does the next quest start?
So the cool thing here is
that the semantic search
can actually understand that
this have the same meaning
in returning us the results.
So let's see how it works.
Let's assume that we have
the generative AI application
and our user is now query what
is the next quest to start.
When it should supposed to start.
So what we are going to do,
we are going to query the foundation model
and to ask them when the
next quest is going to start.
This is a bit cost, costly
and expensive from both cost
and performance perspective,
but once we receive the
data, we can return it
to the client itself.
Now, let's assume that
I'm adding ElastiCache
into the architecture.
I'm using the vector search here,
and the user now try to
generate the same question
for my application, but before that,
I'm going to use the
Amazon Teton to generate
for me the embedding vector.
Once I have the vector
itself, I can fetch the item,
the data from my
ElastiCache vector search.
Because this is the first
time I don't have the data yet
on my cache, I'm going
to receive a cache miss
and now I need to go again
to my foundation model,
ask the question, and
get back the response.
But this time I store the
item on my cache for a woman
for the next time I'm going to read it.
But let's make it even
more cool, more complex.
And now I'm receiving similar query,
not this exact, the same query.
And we can understand
that traditional caching
will not work in that way.
We cannot just store the data on the cache
and expect it to be as a cache
sheet in the next iteration.
And for that, we have the vector search.
So let's go through the flow.
We go to the generative AI,
then we create the embedding vector.
Once we generate the impacting vector now
with a different question,
we are asking the
ElastiCache vector search,
but this time we're going
to receive a cache hit
because contextually, understand
that they have the same context.
And with that way, we
are saving the need to go
to foundation model, which is expensive,
both from cost and performance.
Let's go through the API
itself and see how, it works.
So I'm using here the FT.CREATE
to create the index itself.
I'm going to use hash.
I can use also JSON to store the data
but here, I'm showing an example of hash.
We're using the HSNW as the algorithm
because it works well in
high dimensional space
while very optimized for performance.
I'm going to use here dimensions of 128.
In my previous example,
I show you only three,
but here, I'm going to use more dimensions
and I'm going to use this distance metric,
the cosine algorithm.
Now to search the item, I'm
using closest neighbors retrieve
only 10 in that example
for my vector search.
Now I have another option
that I can filter out
some of the results on the
fly on the server side.
And for that, I'm using the index here.
In that example, I'm using
filtering only for per country.
So in this code that
I'm going to show you,
we populate the vector
store in the text data
that build the foundation
of the semantic search body.
So first, we are going
to load the text data
and to split it into chunks.
And for that, we're going to
use the log chain library.
Next we are going to use the chunk
that converted into embedding
using the embedding model.
And we are using the vector Teton
to use the embedded vectors.
And to query the data, we're
going to use the FT.CREATE
that we use for FT.CREATE.
We are going to store it
first on the vector search.
So to fetch the item, to fetch the data,
we are going to use the FT search.
And we use the same here.
We are going to use the closest neighbors.
Here, we using only three.
And once we have it,
we can search the item
on the vector search itself.
Now I want to call to Kevin to continue
with more advanced use cases.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Cool, let's talk about some
additional data structures
that you can do in
Valkey, starting with one
of the functionalities of
publish and subscribing.
So Valkey, as we talked about before,
is a rich data structure server.
And with our MMORPG, we wanna be able
to answer questions about an in-game chat.
We wanna build a chat functionality
for our game where players can join
and participate in an in-game
chat that's ephemeral.
So let's say here we have
a Shadow Dragons Guild
and a bunch of users
that wanna participate
and communicate with each other.
For that, we can use this
pub/subs feature within Valkey.
So if you're not familiar
with the pub/subpattern,
it's a messaging pattern where
there are producer publishers
of messages that are decoupled
from the subscribers.
So a subscriber comes in and
subscribes to a name topic.
So let's say our topic
here, just Shadow Dragons
and a user can come in
and say, I wanna listen
to messages on this topic.
Another user can come and
publish messages to those topics.
And so I can come say hello
and then anyone that subscribed
to that topic will get those messages.
So how does this work inside Valkey?
So the data here is ephemeral.
Valkey is basically just
used as a messaging bus
so that the data is relayed from producers
to consumers directly.
It's not stored in memory
other than for the transition
between the producer and consumer.
It allows at most, once delivery.
So if you're not listening to the topic
then you'll miss the message.
There is, however another data structure
that we're not gonna go
into today called streams
that allows you to store
messages inside Valkey
and in memory for long-term storage
and has a number of other rich features
such as consumer groups
to be able to resume
where you left off.
But pub/sub is off our choice
for this since the chat
message is just ephemeral here.
So there's two different
types of pub/sub in Valkey.
One is what I call classic pub/sub
and one is sharded pub/sub,
which is a relatively new.
We recommend using sharded pub/sub
because it has better
scalability properties.
So in classic pub/sub, all of the messages
that you send are forwarded to all
of the nodes in the cluster.
So you kind of have this large fan out
and that means any
subscriber can go to any node
and get all of the messages on a topic.
But of course, that doesn't
scale as well as you have
very high volume pub/sub traffic.
Whereas with Sharded pub/sub, just like
with the sharded key space
in cluster mode enabled,
it goes to a particular shard
and all of the producers
and consumers know which shard to go to.
And so the fan out is much smaller.
The main downside of using sharded pub/sub
is it doesn't support these
wild card identifiers.
So you can't subscribe to
a large number of topics.
You have to do a specific name
topic so that you get hashed
to the right shard.
So how does this work in practice?
How do you actually do it?
Let's say we have two users
here that like we had before
of Alice and Bob and
they want to join this
and participate in this chat room.
So for sharded pub/sub we'll
use this SSUBSCRIBE command
for Alice to subscribe
and we'll prefix our
key name here with chat,
and then Shadow Dragons being the name.
It'll return back the
identifier of the topic
as well as the one saying
it's successfully subscribed.
Now, Alice can publish, it
doesn't have to be subscribed,
but she can publish to this message
and we can do any sort of
string to publish to a topic,
but here, we'll format it in
JSON so it has enough metadata
to render the chat in the application.
So we'll do SPUBLISH,
we'll get back a one saying
it's been successfully done and
then immediately after that,
we would get this SMESSAGE
because Alice has also
subscribed to that topic
and the message has in it that the topic
that it was published to as
well as the actual message
that the publisher sent.
Meanwhile, Bob can come along
and subscribe to it,
similar to how Alice did
and then do a publish just
before saying Bob here.
And then that message
shows up on both of them
because they're both
subscribed at the same time.
And so you can build pretty
rich applications this way.
It doesn't require a whole lot of memory
since these messages are just used, stored
transiently and relayed
to the subscribers.
Next, let's look at a couple different
probabilistic data structures
that we'll talk about in Valkey.
Valkey of course, is an
in-memory data structure server.
So storage matters, you
don't want to be able,
you don't wanna have to
store a large amount of data
if you don't have to.
And there are some
applications in our MMORPG
where accuracy isn't paramount.
And so we can get away with answers
that perhaps off by a bit.
So one such example is
a unique user count.
So say we wanna keep track of
how many daily active users,
unique daily active users
are playing our game.
Of course, we can do a counter
and get, you know, non-unique users,
but we want to do something
that is a little bit more advanced.
And so normally, let's say
we wanna do it on a day by day basis.
We have four different users
here that are playing our game.
And traditionally, if you just were to use
a set data structure, it
would take O of N space,
we would store all of
the different username
that are user IDs that are
associated with that counter,
and then we could just take the set
and that way, we'd ensure uniqueness.
But within Valkey, there
is a data structure
called a HyperLogLog.
And this can approximate set cardinality.
So it can answer the question
of how many unique users
you might see.
The advantage here is it's
doesn't take linear space.
It is bounded to 12 kilobytes in Valkey
and it has a less than
1% standard error rate,
which is pretty remarkable.
So how exactly does it
and it allows constant time operations
because it's small, so it
doesn't require, you know,
O of N space or login access.
So what is the intuition
behind how HyperLogLog works?
So say these are some poorly drawn coins
that we're flipping.
If I tell you I'm
flipping a bunch of coins,
but I get five heads in a row, it's likely
that I've flipped a bunch of coins
in order to see a sequence
of five heads in a row.
And this is sort of the intuition
behind how the algorithm works,
is it takes these values, observes them
and then it counts repeating patterns
that are less and less likely over time.
So what does that exactly mean?
The algorithm of
HyperLogLog takes your user
or whatever string that you
want to be able to count.
And it runs it through this murmur hash,
which produces a 64-bit uniformly
distributed binary string.
So it's just a, what
seemingly random value
of zeros and ones.
And in Valkey, it takes the first 14 byte
or bits of that binary value
and computes a hash bucket out of it.
So there's 16,000 buckets
that can be computed
within the HyperLogLog.
And then the remaining digits, it takes
and accounts the number of leading zeros.
And this is the analogy of coin flips.
The larger number of leading zeros
that are happening
in this uniformly
distributed binary string.
The, you know, more values
you may have seen in order
to observe that pattern.
And what it does is it takes the bucket
and then the number of leading zeros
and it stores the maximum number
of leading zeros per bucket
that it has observed
in the sequence of strings
that being added to it.
And then it takes the
harmonic mean of this overall.
So it's a mathematical
equation to basically identify
the total number of observations.
Luckily, you don't have
to actually deal with any
of that math when you're using
the HyperLogLog in Valkey.
It has a pretty simple
API to interact with it,
which is just these PF prefix
and PFADD will add a number
of items into a particular HyperLogLog.
So say, we are want to
name it daily active users
with the date, we can add three to it,
we'll get back a one
saying it's been successful
and if we issue a count command,
then we'll get back three in this case.
And if we were to try
and add the same user, it'll
come up with the same hash,
it shouldn't modify it.
We'll get back a zero saying
it has been unsuccessful
and the count is unchanged in this case.
There's some other interesting
properties here too.
So say we wanna be able to subdivide it,
we now wanna, instead of
just doing daily active users
over the entire MMORPG,
we wanna kind of partition
it into different games.
So we can add three, the
three users to game one
and maybe just Alice and
Doris to game two here.
So they're different HyperLogLogs.
HyperLogLogs are composable.
So we can use this command called PFMERGE
where we can take the two of them.
And it basically goes through
in that data structure we talked about
and just updates the max
number of leading zeros
based off of the number in each bucket.
And it allows you to then get a total sum
of unique users across
multiple HyperLogLogs.
So in this case, we have
only four unique users
even though we've had five
different observations.
So we'll get back a four when we count
that aggregated HyperLogLog.
So I ran a quick little
simulation of the memory usage
and error rate of a set and a HyperLogLog.
So in adding 10,000 numbers to a set,
you'd get back 10,000 exactly
because it's storing every
single number in the string
and then calculating that cardinality.
But the memory usage of
the set as calculated
by Valkey is about 420 kilobytes.
Whereas doing the same
thing with a HyperLogLog,
I got back 9,987.
So a 0.13% error,
but the memory usage here is 12 kilobytes.
So you can see that that 12 kilobytes
will not expand beyond that.
It's the maximum size of the HyperLogLog,
but the set usage would
increase with the number
of unique users that get added.
Next, let's answer a
slightly different question
of whether two players know each other.
So say you wanna keep track of your game,
whether you've observed or interacted
with a player before,
basically, forms this
graph that you'd have
to keep track of the different
users that have engaged
with each other, which
you could store in Valkey
with sets again.
We have the different interactions
for each individual player.
The downside of course
is that this is also O of N storage space.
So can we do better than that?
Can we not have to store
all these sort of common combinations?
And with that we can use a bloom filter,
which is a relatively recent
data structure added to Valkey.
And as answers a different question,
it answers the membership
testing question.
So whether a given user has interacted
with the particular user
that you're querying for.
This can result in over
90% memory usage savings
over a set, depending
on your configuration.
Unlike the HyperLogLog,
this has some configuration options,
it has this tuneable false positive rate
that you're able to tune.
The lower the false positive rate,
the higher the memory usage
of that data structure.
But by default it stores it
is a 1% false positive rate.
So the error that you can get
is that you would've seen interacted
with someone when in reality,
you hadn't done that.
This is also a constant time operation.
It uses a number of
different hash functions,
which we'll see in a
minute in order to test
and to add members to this set.
But it's typically a relatively
a small constant time.
So how does this work under the cover?
So the intuition is that you
have this fixed size bit array
that has a number of
different hash functions
that operate on it.
So say for this example,
we have 10 bits here
and we wanna add Bob to it.
So let's say we just
have two hash functions.
We'll calculate the hash one of bob
and then modular it by the number of bits
and we get bit number five.
We'll go and update that in our bid array
and we'll do the same thing
with the second hash function here,
which is another unique hash function.
We'll get the value of nine
and we'll update those too.
And we can do the same thing
with Alice, with everyone
that we add goes through
the same function,
uses this murmur hash as well.
Well we can update Alice here.
There's conflict, you get back five
and five is already one, we
don't do anything with it.
And let's say hash two of
Alice is the first position.
And so we'll go and update that.
Let's go back one second.
So when you go and test membership,
it goes through the
same exact process too.
So say we want to check to see
if someone else is present,
we'll go through and observe each
whether the bits that are
hashed are one or zero.
And this is why because the hash function
is non-unique, you can
have false positives.
So in this case, we can see
that that Alice was not previously added,
that that first bit is a zero.
But some, if for example the
you get back position bit five
and bit nine for another user,
then you might have a false positive
where it conflicted with Bob.
So if they're all zero or
you know, at least one zero,
then it was definitely
never added to the set.
But if all of the values
that we look at are one,
then it was maybe added
to the set previously.
So we don't have to actually
store the underlying strings,
just basically some representation
of the hashed value.
So the memory usage savings
are pretty significant here.
So if you look at the a
1% false positive rate,
you can get about 112 million
items with 128 megabytes
or scaling linearly, 448
million items with 512.
And if you were to drop
the false positive rate
to 0.1%, then you can get,
using the same memory usage,
you have still a relatively
large capacity, 74 million
with 128 megs or 298 million with 512.
And of course, you can kinda
tune this as your needs fit.
How do you actually use this in Valkey?
So again, it has a relatively simple API
where you can just interact
with it as you would've set.
So there's this BFADD
command which allows you
to add strings into a given bloom filter.
And we get back a one here
saying Bob has been added.
We can similarly add
multiple users simultaneously
atomically to the interactions here.
And then this exists is the
membership testing command
where you can just test
if a given user was there,
we'll get back a zero.
However, and Bob of course
would return back one
saying that it does
exist, it has been added,
but what can happen
is that you get back
a false positive here.
So we're testing whether
Frank has been added
to the interactions with Alice,
but we get it will conflict
in this case with either Bob,
Charlie or Doris's hash
values and we get back a one.
So let's move on to another data structure
within Valkey that can keep
track of geospatial data.
So let's say we are managing our MMORPG
and we have this, you
know, virtual rich world
where users are in different locations
and we wanna see which users
and points of interest are
located near a given user
at a point in time.
And for this, we can use the
ALKIS geospatial commands.
So what is geospatial?
So how does it work?
So in Valkey, you would map first
with a latitude and longitude.
Basically, you would
take your virtual world
and divide it into a normal grid here.
That latitude longitude
that you store as input
is taken into a geohash algorithm
and stored as a traditional
geo hash, which it works
by sort of subdividing the world
into smaller and smaller grids.
And it generates this normal geo hash
is a string of characters.
We would take it into a
sort of this 52 bit integer.
And the properties of the
integer are interesting
in that the closer these numbers are,
the closer they are in
location to each other
because of the way that it interleaves
the latitude and longitude.
And this has the nice property
that you can kinda use it as a score.
So things that are close to each other
and numerically are close
to each other in latitude and longitude.
And so this score is then fed
into another data structure
within Valkey called assorted set.
Sorted sets are often used
for things like leaderboards
where you just have high scores,
you wanna be able to keep
track of like the top end.
In this case, the sorted
set is actually used
to query things
that are nearby a given
latitude and longitude.
However, it has some convenience
functions on top of it.
So this allows you to
just sort of bounding box
and radius querying in O of log N time.
So how would you actually
use it in practice?
So let's see how it works.
You'd have these geo add commands.
So it has these convenience functions
on top of the sorted set.
You can do a geo add with
different latitude longitude.
Here, we're adding Alice as
well as a point of interest
of the beach down here on the bottom.
We'll get back a one saying
it's been successfully added.
And then let's say we
have another player here
that wants to query
for the points of interest around them.
So you use this geo radius
command and you query the map.
It has a slightly different
latitude longitude.
So we can do different radii here.
So let's say we do a
three kilometer radius,
we would get back both
items that we've added here,
Alice as well as the beach at the bottom.
However, if we were to
do a smaller radius here,
just a one kilometer radius
among along that point,
we would just get back Alice.
So you can use it to
query things around it.
You can then use it to
kind of filter further
so that you can query the
distance between any two points
in that as well and get it back
in a number of different units.
So say we wanna see the
distance between Alice
and beach one in meters
and get back that it's about
1,600 meters between them.
So you can use it to
further filter the results
of the radius if you wanna do
things like bounding boxes.
Now let's look at a usage
of rate limiting in our application.
So you might wanna use
rate limiting in an MMORPG
to enforce game mechanics here.
So let's say we wanna answer the question,
does a player have enough
stamina to cast a give
and spell at a point in time?
So as Bob is trying to access
a resource, in this case,
spell casting and can only do
so many spells in a certain time period
before that quota resets.
So we can do this simply in Valkey
using a counter effectively,
and the string data type here can be used
to also support numerical operations.
So you have some increment
and decrement commands in
Valkey to manipulate numbers.
So if I were to increment
just to give counter here,
it'll create it and set it to one
and I can further manipulate that
and you know, if I increment
it again, it'll go to two.
And this is of course a
constant time operation
that you're performing.
And so we can use this
to build a rate limiter
for Valkey for our application.
So let's say we wanna be able
to start our counter here
at zero and allow three requests
until a given time delay is up.
So you just have three requests,
let's say in a like a five second period.
So what we can do is we
can start our counter
and use a Lua script
to do this atomic logic
to be able to count return back of value,
and then make sure it expires at the end
of that time period.
So we'll use a TTL basically
to reset our rate limiter
at the end of the duration.
So just looking at this
numerically, users trying
to offer requests, we'll
count up to three here.
And then once it gets to three,
no more requests are allowed
until the TTL fires.
As soon as the TTL fires
that item is basically
removed from the cache
and then that same
process can restart again
as if the user has sufficient credits.
So let's walk through that Lua
script to see how it works.
So as I said,
Valkey supports some
simple scripting operations
where you can do compound
operations atomically.
In a Lua script.
Lua a language that you
might not be familiar with,
but it's relatively straightforward.
It can interact with the server command
to do simple logic on top of it.
So let's say we have a
couple different globals here
in our script.
We wanna set our limit to three
and our expire time would be
four seconds in this case.
We'll start by fetching the key
that we're operating on.
In this case, the given user's stamina.
And we'll fetch it
from the Valkey server
that we're running on.
If it doesn't exist,
meaning that it hasn't
either has been evicted
or it's starting from scratch,
then we'll set it to zero
and set the expiry time to four seconds.
And if it does exist,
then we have already
previously fetched the value
and then we just check if
we're within our limit.
If we are, then we'll be
able to increment the key
and return one saying
that the user's allowed to cast the spell.
Otherwise, we'll return zero.
So this is sufficient to
build a simple rate limiter
that just allows a specific number.
But let's say we wanna have something
that's a little bit more, oh,
let's see how you actually use it too.
Let's, so we can load the script first
by just inserting it into Valkey.
We can do script load
and put that entire string
that you just saw before
into the server, which then
gives you back this SHA ID.
This is the unique identifier
hash value of the script
that you can then use in a
subsequent to invoke that script.
So then you can do eval SHA, the script ID
and then pass at the arguments here.
Like we saw before,
we wanna give it the key
name, the number of spells
that Bob has placed in
this particular example.
And it will then return back a one
or a zero, whether that
is an allowed spell
or a disallowed spell.
This is relatively simple,
but let's say we wanna have
spells that have different types
of a different cost.
So it can do a simple spell
or a more complex spell.
So our previous example
wouldn't have worked with that
because it just allows a simple counter.
And with this, we can do a token bucket,
which is a little bit more
advanced rate limiting algorithm
where you have a given capacity
and refill rate of that bucket.
And if the bucket has enough
credits for your given spell,
we'll subtract from it,
otherwise, it will be disallowed.
So we keep track of a little
bit more metadata associated
with a given user's spell count here.
We can do this in Valkey by
using the hash data structure
that Yaron talked about.
And for this, we need to keep track
of two different pieces of information.
One is the number of tokens
that work are currently in the bucket,
and two is the last time we
updated or touched that bucket.
And you need the timestamp
because tokens accrue over time.
And so you can calculate
the difference there.
So let's break down what
the script looks like
in this scenario.
Still using Lua script,
but it's a little bit more complex
so we can look at some
advanced Lua scripting here.
So rather than having hardcoded values,
like global values in the script before,
we're gonna take in these
values as arguments here.
So we have the bucket size
and the refill rate as
arguments to the script
as well as the number of
tokens for the given request.
And we still get the key out.
So the first thing we need
to do is get the value
of the hash, which may or may not exist
if we haven't run this before.
So we'll fetch using HMGET
as well as the current time,
which is a value, a command within balkey.
The first step is to refill the bucket.
So we check to see if
there was an update time
and if that exists, then we'll go ahead
and calculate the difference
in terms of credits.
We'll refill the bucket as the first step.
And this means you don't have
to be running this periodically.
You can just run it any time
that you need to query it
and it will refill the
bucket up to the max size.
If the bucket's already at the max size
or if it's beyond that, then we'll just go
and reset it to the max capacity.
And then we need to determine
if the request is allowed.
So if we have enough tokens,
if our current token count
is more than the number
of requested tokens, then,
we will subtract and allow the request.
Otherwise, it will be disallowed
and the number of tokens are not updated.
And then we'll go and
update that data structure
to represent the current number
of tokens in the last update time.
And lastly, we'll do
some optimization here.
We could keep this hash in
the data structure forever
and it'll eventually get updated,
but you know, say the user
goes away, we wanna be able
to reap these at some point in time.
And so we can again use the TTL
to expire this hash data
structure at the point
where basically it would
have reached the ceiling
of the bucket capacity anyway.
And so we'll take the bucket
size by the refill rate
and just expired at that point in time.
And with that, I want
to thank you for coming
and we'll be available off the side here
to answer any questions that
you may have about Valkey
or data structure modeling.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)